el anuncio de las autoridades alemanas
de imponer restricciones fronterizas con
francia en particular con el
departamento francés de modela que
limita con los estados federados de
alemania responde a la alta presencia de
la variante sudafricana de coronavirus
en esa región francesa y responde
también a la gran preocupación que hay
aquí en alemania por las variantes del
coronavirus algunas de las cuales son
consideradas particularmente contagiosas
con el potencial de aumentar
considerablemente el número de
infectados por corona virus en el país a
partir del próximo martes quienes
transiten en esa región fronteriza hacia
alemania deberán presentar un test
negativo de coronavirus y la medida
también implica que trenes buses y
aviones no podrán llevar a personas
entre modela y alemania- hay algunas
excepciones como por ejemplo para
residentes en alemania los ciudadanos
alemanes y también se espera que el
transporte de mercancías no se vea
afectado modela así se suma a otros 15
países o regiones
están en una lista de las autoridades
alemanas considerados particularmente
peligrosos por la presencia de variantes
de coronavirus en esa lista están por
ejemplo brasil portugal sudáfrica reino
unido o irlanda además de la región
austriaca de tirol fronteriza con
alemania y también república checa-
tanto con tirol como con república checa
alemania ya tiene controles fronterizos